hello and welcome to math simplified
in this video we will talk about how to
treat constipation
at home constipation is one of the most
common digestive problems in the world
affecting more than 2.5 million people
every year in the united states alone
most people think constipation means not
having
frequent enough bowel movements but in
reality
constipation is more complicated and
more subtle than that
with the range of symptoms that you may
not always recognize
in this video we will talk about the
most common reasons why constipation
occurs
and the three simple steps that you can
do to prevent
and treat constipation we will also
discuss about lifestyle modifications
that help to relieve constipation
people think if they are having bowel
movements every day
they cannot be constipated but medical
definition of constipation
actually requires a person to have just
one of these symptoms
that include less than three bowel
movements
per week straining to start or complete
a power movement
stool consistency that looks like rocks
and pebbles
or a feeling of incomplete emptying
constipation can happen for many reasons
such as when stools pass through the
colon at a slower speed
than they should the slower the food
moves through the digestive tract
the more water the colon will absorb and
the harder the feces will become
a person who poops fewer than three
times per week may have constipation
constipation can result from several
underlying reasons
they can include dietary changes such as
low fiber intake
or not drinking enough fluids eating
excessive meat or chicken history of
colon surgery
diabetes history of gastrointestinal
disorders such as
irritable bowl syndrome history of
pelvic floor disorders
or history of intestinal obstruction and
pregnancy
it can also result from taking certain
medications such as
aluminium and calcium containing
antacids
anti-convulsants calcium channel
blockers
diuretics iron supplements narcotic pain
medications
and medicines used to treat parkinson's
disease
another very common reason of
constipation is physical
inactivity lower levels of physical
activity may
also lead to constipation some past
studies have found that physically fit
people
including marathon runners are less
likely to experience constipation than
other people
although the exact reasons for this
remain unclear
a study from 2013 concluded that
increasing physical activity in the form
of regular exercise
helps to improve constipation among
older adults
people who spend several days or weeks
in bed
or sitting in a chair due to some
medical conditions have a higher risk of
constipation
dehydration is one of the most common
causes of chronic constipation
the food you eat makes it way from your
stomach to the large intestines
or colon if you don't have enough water
in your body already
the large intestine soaks up water from
your food waste
this makes you have hard stools that are
difficult to pass
sometimes the movement of colon slows
for no known reason
leading to constipation so usually the
most common cause of constipation is low
intake of fiber
people with a high intake of dietary
fiber are less likely to experience
constipation
and that brings us to the first point
about how to prevent and treat
constipation
which is dietary modifications dietary
modification
is the most important step to treat
constipation
it is more important than any other
medicine you can take
because medicines can only improve the
short term episode of constipation
in most of the cases the real reason
behind why you get constipated
is because of the poor dietary choices
in the form of low intake of fiber
excessive consumption of junk food and
foods high in fat
and sugar so the first and foremost
dietary modification
that you should implement is addition of
more fiber
to your diet this is because fiber
promotes regular bowel movements
especially when a person combines it
with proper hydration
dietary fiber increases the weight and
size of your stools
and softens them a bulky stool is easier
to pass
decreasing your chance of constipation
the average american adult
gets about 15 grams of fiber daily
much less than we actually need
according to the american dietic
association
women younger than 51 should aim for 25
grams of fiber daily
and men younger than 51 should aim for
38 grams of fiber daily
high fiber foods include fruits
vegetables
whole grains nuts lentils
chickpeas and other legumes low fiber
foods
include high fat food such as cheese
meat
and eggs highly processed foods such as
white bread
and fast foods chips and other pre-made
foods
the next dietary change we will focus on
is drinking plenty of water
you should drink plenty of water and
other liquids such as naturally
sweetened fruit and vegetable juices
and clear soups that will help you to
help the fiber work better
this change should make your stools
softer and easier to pass
when your body is properly hydrated less
water will be withdrawn from the colon
this will keep your stools soft and easy
to pass
another dietary modification is to
include probiotics in your diet
as some of you may know our gut contains
healthy bacteria
that are normal commensals of our body
and are very important for the proper
digestion of food
probiotics are live bacteria and yeasts
that are good for your digestive system
many types of bacteria are classified as
probiotics
they all have different benefits but
most come
from two groups lactobacillus and
bifidobacterium
the most important role of probiotics is
in treating antibiotic induced diarrhea
because when we take antibiotics for
longer duration it damages the good
bacteria in our gut
which can lead to malabsorption and
ultimately diarrhea
well the question here is do probiotics
provide relief from constipation
researchers at king's college in london
did a study in which they divided people
who had constipation into two groups one
group
was given probiotics for two weeks and
the second group didn't receive
the probiotics the researchers found
that probiotics
increased the number of weekly ball
movements
and helped soften the stools making them
easier to pass
probiotics that contained
bifidobacterium appear to be the most
effective
this study was published in the american
journal of clinical nutrition
i have included links to some of the
best probiotics in the description box
down below
so make sure to check them out now let's
look at some foods that you should avoid
to prevent constipation and the number
one in the list
is alcohol alcohol is frequently
mentioned as a likely cause of
constipation
that's because if you drink alcohol in
large amounts it can increase
the amount of fluids lost through your
urine causing dehydration
poor hydration either due to not
drinking enough water
or losing too much of it through urine
is often linked to an increased risk of
constipation
another type of foods that you should
avoid to prevent constipation
is gluten containing foods gluten is a
protein found in grains like
wheat barley and rye some people may
experience constipation when they eat
foods that contain gluten
also some people are intolerant to
gluten
this is a condition known as gluten
intolerance or celiac disease
you should also decrease the amount of
milk and dairy products that you consume
in your diet dairy appears to be another
common reason of constipation
at least for some people infants
toddlers and children appear
particularly at risk
possibly due to a sensitivity to
proteins found in cow's milk
and there are reports of similar
experiences in adults also
you should also decrease your
consumption of red meat
red meat may worsen constipation due to
many reasons
first it contains little fiber which
adds bulk to the stools
and helps to move them along furthermore
unlike other types of meat such as
poultry and fish
red meat generally contains higher
amounts of fat and high fat foods
take longer for the body to digest in
some cases this may increase the
likelihood of constipation even further
other types of foods that you should
avoid if you suffer from constipation
are fried or fast foods and processed
grains
so now that we have discussed about diet
related changes for treating
constipation
let's talk about some lifestyle
modifications you should implement
that will help you to manage
constipation number one
is to exercise regularly according to
experts
exercise does more than tone your heart
and other muscles
exercise is essential for regular power
movements
in fact one of the key things that leads
to constipation
is inactivity about 30 minutes of
moderate exercise per day
is optimum number two is stress
management
stress can contribute to many conditions
and constipation is one of them
try meditation relaxation going to bed
earlier and deep breathing to manage
your stress
number three is bald retraining bowel
retraining
is important as it helps people who have
chronic constipation
it involves trying to go to the bathroom
at the same time
every day in an attempt to help train
your body to have regular bowel
movements
you will need to set a time each day in
which you try to have a bowel movement
after several weeks you will ideally
have a bowel movement around the same
time every day
choose a regular time each day to try to
have a bald movement
as a general rule the best time is 20 to
40 minutes after eating
most doctors recommend going in the
morning about 20 minutes
after eating breakfast spend 10 to 15
minutes on the toilet to see if you can
have bowel movement
make sure you don't strain as you try to
go
if you don't pass a stool resume your
regular daily activities
remember that it can take time to train
your bowels so try not to worry about
your inability to have a bowel movement
at first
other minor lifestyle modifications that
are proven to be effective to relieve
constipation
include eating your meals around the
same time
each day drinking a glass of water right
after you wake up
do some light exercise such as walking
after breakfast
and dinner take a 20 minute walk during
your lunch break
pack a piece of fruit to eat as a snack
during the day
substitute white bread with whole wheat
bread and white rice
with brown rice get enough sleep
when you have the urge to have a power
movement use the bathroom
right away don't hold it now that we are
done with the diet and lifestyle changes
that you should do
let's talk about some medication that is
used to treat constipation
the first line medications that are used
to treat constipation are known as
laxatives now there are a lot of
different types of laxatives with
different mechanisms of actions
but in simple terms laxatives can be
defined as a type of medicine
that helps a person empty their bowels
laxatives can be taken orally by mouth
in the form of liquids tablets or
capsules
they can also be taken through the
rectum for example suppositories and
anemias
like any medication laxatives can have
side effects which we will discuss
later laxatives are of different types
depending upon their mechanisms of
actions broadly laxatives can be divided
into
four main groups the first one is the
bulk forming laxatives also known as
fiber supplements these work in the same
way that fiber
in a diet normally does fiber works by
increasing the water content
and bulk of the stools which helps to
move it quickly through the colon
when taking fiber supplements it is
essential to drink enough water
they usually take 12 to 14 hours to have
an effect
adults with constipation should start
taking bulk forming laxatives first
the next category of laxatives is known
as osmotic laxatives
the word osmotic is derived from the
word osmosis
which basically means movement of water
osmotic laxatives are small particles
which can be proteins
fibers or sugar that promote the net
movement of water
into the center of the colon through the
process of osmosis
the result of using osmotic laxatives in
the intestine
is to draw water into the center of the
colon resulting in softer
and more easily passed stools next we
have stimulant laxatives
as their name indicates they are
stimulants stimulant lactates trigger
the intestines to contract
and push out the stools and due to their
mechanism of action
they are fast acting laxatives that
induce bowel movements by
increasing the contraction of muscles in
the intestines
and are very effective when used
properly the last category of laxatives
are known as emollient laxatives also
known as
tool softeners stool softeners increase
bowel movements by helping the water in
our colon
to mix into the stools easily which
prevents dry and hard stool masses
these laxatives are effective in
reducing straining
during passage of souls however they are
the least effective option for treating
constipation
they are best for people with temporary
constipation or mild chronic
constipation
i have included links to some of the
best laxatives available online in the
description box down below
so you can check them out to start the
treatment you should
first use bulk forming laxatives as they
are the safest
and quite effective also psyllium husk
is a good bulk laxative psyllium is a
form
of fiber made from husks of seeds of
plant
known as plantago ovata it is also known
as isfal
besides keeping your ball movements
regular and managing
chronic condition of constipation
psyllium has the ability to
soften your stools provided you drink
enough water
other examples of bulk laxatives are
methyl cellulose and
carboxy methyl cellulose in people who
don't get relief from bulk laxatives
alone the addition of
other laxatives is often the next step
in the management of constipation
and the next type of laxative that is
prescribed is usually
an osmotic laxative lactulose and
polyethylene glycol
are most oftenly used osmotic laxatives
as they are quite effective
and safe the recommended dose of
lactulose for adults is 15 to 30
milliliters
once or twice daily laterals containing
laxatives start
working in one day usually loose is a
good brand that contains
lactulose and miralax and lactolite
are some good brands that contain
polyethylene glycol
if the patient still doesn't get relief
from constipation
the next step is to add a stimulant
laxative stimulant laxatives increase
intestinal motility and intestinal
secretion
they begin working within a few hours
bisacodyl is a good and safe stimulant
laxative that is available over the
counter
by the brand name dulcolax visacodel is
a useful laxative
especially suitable for single dose used
in patients with temporary constipation
another example of stimulant laxative is
sodium picosulfate
widely available under the brand names
cremafin and cremalax
it is quite effective but can cause
diarrhea and loose tools
if you still don't get relief from
constipation
or you have severe chronic constipation
interventions like
enemas and suppositories can be tried
animals are rectal injections of fluids
intended to cleanse or stimulate the
emptying of your bowel
suppositories are solid medications that
are inserted in the body
through the rectum suppositories contain
one or
other type of laxatives usually
stimulant laxatives like bisacotyl
and stool softeners like sodium docusite
another drug that is recently launched
for treating constipation
is lubi prostone lubiprostone increases
water secretion in the intestine
which makes the stool soft and it also
increases the speed at which the food
moves through our colon
it comes by the brand names lubilax and
luber well
it is given in a dose of 8 to 24
micrograms twice daily
so i hope friends with this video i was
able to give you some information about
constipation and its treatment if you
found this video helpful make sure to
support us by becoming a member of our
channel
or joining our community at
patreon.comsimplified
also you can share this video with
someone who might find it useful
thank you so much for watching see you
in the next video